Bốn 15 kẹ tự khi đất nước đổi mới, Việt Nam hiện có được bị thế ngày càng cao trên triệu quốc tế.
Góc ý cho dự thảo văn kẹt đại hội mối bốn của đàn, nhiều ý kiến cho rằng những bài học quý giá của ngoại giao bốn 15 quà sẽ tiếp tục soại sáng còn đường phát triển của đất nước.
Trong xuất gần bốn thập kỳ qua, đường lối đối ngoại đã phương ngoại đã giản hóa quản hệ quốc tế, Việt Nam là bản là đối tác tin cạnh và là thành viên có chách nghiệm cuộc công đồng quốc tế,
trở thành kinh trị Nam cho hoạt động đối ngoại của Việt Nam.
Tại dự thảo văn kinh trịnh đại hội mối bốn của đàn, đối ngoại hội nhập quốc tế được đề xuất đặt lên năng hàng với quốc phòng và an ninh,
trở thành nhiệm vụ chọng yếu thường suyên để xuất này nhật được sự đánh giá cao từ các nhà ngoại giao.
Trong đào mối khoảng tỉnh mối mới có kích tâm thế và bị thế mới của đất nước.
Thì chúng ta có lù, kinh năng được, để chúng ta chủ đất kính tạng.
Chào đầy có, chủ đồng đến đạo xích hết, là kế vị thể cho đến nữa.
Chào đồng kính tạng đối phòng, là kính mối chung phật lợi cho đến nữa.
Đó là chúng ta thъm ra và kính tạng suy giữ các lợi trời của tốt tế, vụ hợi lợi phát tỉnh năng, vụ hợi lợi phát tốt tế.
Việt năng có một nền ngoại giao rất thành công trong tả môi năng qua, rất nước đã thoát khỏi kting trạng
cô lợi và chiến tranh chờ thành trung tâm của sự quả hợp giữa các cuông ra.
Nếu nền vào quanh hệ của trứng tôi với diễn năng trong mai m거를 năng qua, có thể thấy nhờ chính xác ngoại giao diệu qua,
việt năng việt đã chuẩn thành một trong những đối tác thương mặt chính của những mình choo.
có phát triển bà tình, mình sẽ không có phát triển bà tình.
Góp ý vào sự thảo văn kiện nhiều chiếc thức,
kêu bà ho vẻ nằm tại nước ngoài,
mong muốn sự thảo văn kiện tại hội mùi bốn của đàn.
Cần giãnh mạnh việc, coi chiếc thức, và mạnh lưới kiện nằm toàn cầu,
là đặc lực quan trọng đến năng tầm bị thế quốc gia.
Xin sống tệ nước ngoài, chúng tôi nhận ra, mà thân không chỉ là những cá nhân đến lệ.
Mà hòn được kết nối với nhau quan hình đến nước, và chỉ chúng tôi phải có một.
Hình chính giãnh trong việc tàn em quý tìm của Việt Nam.
Hãy sao? Mạnh kích nả, lỗi chính là bàn kết nọng có tích cực vào đưa sống kinh đề và sáng hội của cúch ra sửa tài.
Và chính như vậy, tôi hi vọng đàn sẽ có thêm có chỉ khu thệ để tập đồng người việc ở nước ngoài.
Đặc biệt là thế, chỉ tức trẻ.
Có thể kết nối, hợp thác bà hôm trợ lận nhau hiệu quả hơi.
Dự thảo văn kiện trình đại hội mùi bốn, đặt ra một điều đến năm 2018,
CDP bình quân đầu người phải đặt tắm nhìn năm 2018, Việt Nam sẽ thành nước đàn phát triển có thu nhập Trung bình cao.
Để đặt một điều đến ra, Việt Nam cần một loạt đổi mới, đặc biệt là cải kết về thế trẻ để phục vụ một điều phát triển.
Nói ra Việt Nam, được kì vọng tiếp tục làm bối tiên phong, tạo dựng thế và lực mới cho đất lực.